c'est vrai qu'il ya beaucoup de doc sur
loana vous êtes de ceux qui pensent
qu'il faut la laisser tranquille ou
qu'il faut la mettre en lumière miss
mini chupa michmich allons-y
c'est compliqué c'est vrai que à mon
avis là aujourd'hui c'est les 20 ans du
loft donc ces occasions pour elle on a
des opportunités et elle a besoin d'être
dans la lumière
donc ça c'est vraiment important c'est
ce qu'il a fait vivre c'est un peu ça
dope quelque part mais il peut y avoir
effectivement le contrecoup parce que
pendant ce moment là où elle a cette
possibilité de faire ses émissions cc
uniquement c'est très éphémère ça veut
dire que dans deux mois ce sera terminé
donc l'idée c'est que il faut vraiment
que que s'éloigne de tout ça et qu'elle
revienne vraiment à une autre vie il
faudrait qu'elle puisse rebondir mais
après est ce qu elle en a la capacité
aussi c'est ça la difficulté c'est à
dire que elle est consciente
effectivement de de ça elle est très
dissidents sur pas mal de choses j'ai eu
l'occasion
est ce que ta mère va pas se mentir ça
dépend des jours ben oui c'est ça l'aca
problème parce que vous vous qui le
connaissez bien
est ce qu'à votre sens loana elle a
besoin de rêver mais ce qu'elle était en
capacité est ce que le public parce que
hier soir moi j'ai vu le reportage sais
pas vous mais moi ça fait plus de peine
même chose donc vous qui la connaissent
et est ce qu'elle est capable de deux je
sais pas quand elle veut et elle veut
revenir à la télé parce qu'elle allait
elle a l'air faible quand même 20 mai j
pc c'est vrai que franchement le doc sur
le coup on peut penser que ça fait de la
peine
moi j'étais quand même super content
parce que ça nous rappelle à notre
propre expérience aussi et je me dis que
du coup il ya plein de gens qui
pensaient que loana c'était juste une
bimbo
franchement il n'a pas intelligente
j'aime bien parce que le dock qui prouve
quand même que cette meuf elle était
belle sensible gentille a été
intelligente et working girl
enfin voila moi je voulais juste que il
est comme ça une empreinte en dix ans le
voilà c'est pas n'importe qui quand même
et donc du coup ben au moins je me
disais ça ça fait plaisir
après j'avoue je pense que là il faut en
finir là il faut faire les 20 ans faut
bien le faire faut se marrer c'est sur
ça que je suis là pour ça
elle a un ami dans le sud je pense que
ça peut être le point d'ancrage pour
tout quitter et effectivement la fin du
don qu'elle est complètement pathos en
pensant qu'elle va venir une heure faire
muter pmp à le vendredi non non on ne
veut pas des miettes
c'est le cas de le dire mon coeur ou
bien on va redire évidemment un petit
peu sourd c'est sur cette folie parce
que pour ceux qui nous regardent qui
n'ont pas connu de l'ofs ça a été un
délai absolu et christophe à remonter
non pas comme je le lis très souvent
l'avenue des champs elysées en voiture
comme pour il ya beaucoup de monde mais
l'avenue de la grande armée
vous sortez du loft vous êtes donc le
gagnant faut le rappeler ce que c'est
quand même le domaine on a découvert il
avait gagné une fois qu'il était sorti
parce qu'on n'avait pas eu ces images
découvrez le vainqueur d'une offre qu'on
n'avait pas vu loana on a plein dans
cette maison notamment ce soir où elle
s'est enfui pour échapper à la pression
médiatique et je mettais à enfuis
pendant trois jours parce qu'il y avait
beaucoup trop de monde aux portes et
ayasse lors de choses mais au bout de
trois ans je suis rentré c'est un copain
qui est qu'ils avaient rentré de voiture
et je suis rentré je suis sorti avec un
foulard je me suis enfermé dans une
villa avec des amis à moi et on a fait
un peu la fête
pour souffler un peu web
voilà en fait c'était pas tout à fait
l'extrême et vous le verrez pour le
prime le 8 avril sur site n'était pas la
remontée de la biennale ans d'arrêt vous
parliez justement de ce retour éventuel
sur tpb
on verra des extraits on va parler juste
après ou pas ou pas j'ai pour avancer il
me faut voir un peu plus de folie
pour y arriver il faut que parce que
sinon j'ai l'impression servir à rien
alors il ya un truc mais que les mois
bien faire c'est être chroniqueuse chez
chez cyril hanouna atp mp ça lui donne
un objectif toutes les semaines
toutes les semaines on se dit voilà j'ai
une télé je dois me proposait je dois
être bien j'y vois là il faut pas
qu'elle reste chez elle à tourner en
rond à rien faire faut que les quelque
chose qu'elles soient occupés tu vois
wimax alimentaire même si j'adore se
complaisant ça ressemblait plus à un cv
vidéo de linkedin aurait perdu pied à
peine déguisée pour devenir chroniqueuse
qu'elle se reconstruise et qu'elles
puissent ensuite peut-être amortir les
coûts du rythme médiatique je pense que
là encore un peu trop faible pour
revenir sous les feux des projecteurs
et lui il veut pas perdre je trouve
vraiment le travail de guillaume genton
a été exceptionnel parce qu'il est d'une
bienveillance extraordinaire et ça il
faut le dire et c'est vrai que vous
l'avez vous l'avez dit donc bravo à lui
je trouve que vraiment c'est important
de mettre la lumière sur elle parce que
c'est un peu enfin c'est un peu l'enfant
de la france aussi loana parce qu on se
souvient tous des ailes on a tous eu sa
réussite on a tous vu de son succès puis
on a vu sa dégringolade
on a tous envie lui tendre la main et de
l'aider donc on est tous attachés à
loana et ce reportage il était
nécessaire parce qu'on avait besoin même
nous d'avoir de ses nouvelles et de
comprendre ce qui lui arrive
pour mieux l'aider et pour mieux essayer
de faire ce qu'on peut tous en tant que
public son public presque on a tous été
son public mais c'est vrai qu'on a tous
en nous quelque chose de loana et vous
parlez des descentes aux enfers alors
quand on voit le dock
moi je vais vous dire je pense que la
descente aux enfers commence plus tôt
qu'elle ne le reconnaît et après on en
reparlera ensemble mais c'est vrai que
je pense que ça arrive à la sortie du
loft des saint tropez
mais bon oui on est d'accord c'est
qu'elle est d'accord mais c'est vrai que
ça a été une lente descente aux enfers
qui s'est accélérée avec de nombreuses
tentatives de suicide de regarder la
drogue
l'alcool et les médicaments je crois que
je me suis réfugié dans toutes les
addictions pour pouvoir oublier pour
pouvoir pouvoir arrêter de réfléchir et
parfois pour pouvoir entre sens à ma vie
il y en a eu certaines c'était des
appels au secours je me rappelle de
troyes où c'était des vrais parce que
les vrais c'est c'est là où on l'a
prévoit la tentative de suicide
on regarde pour la dernière fois le
soleil se coucher et puis on dit que
c'est maintenant et puis on prend un
maximum de cacher et on a les yeux qui
se ferme et on dit que c'est pour la
dernière fois christophe et jeudi quand
vous découvrez ce qu'elle dit la bon
c'est pas vraiment une surprise que
honnête on dans l'offre vous avez senti
qu'elle était fragile ou pas oui dans
l'homme qui avait déjà cette bipolarité
entre guillemets c'est vrai qu'elle
passait beaucoup de temps dans la
chambre seul et après sur les moments de
fête elle était là mais ça ça ça nous
rappelle franchement nos propres
histoires on est tous un peu comme ça on
a on a une sensibilité d'un côté être
capable de faire la fête
elle a eu très tôt ella ella ella ce
manque sentimentale qu'on a on est un
peu tous on est un peu tous des cassos
de ce côté là le manque de papa divorce
tous ces trucs là on avait tous envie
d'être aimé donc on y va parce qu'on a
une blessure au coeur et derrière la
célébrité c'est comme un patch à mon
avis ça marche tant que ça peu et après
il y en a qui ont de la chance nous on
s'est rencontrés on a réussi à faire une
vie
les autres aussi et y'a que loana qui a
attendu qui s'est raccroché sa passe
comme elle le dit là que ça et ça c'est
ça qui fait vous serrez c'est pas fini
moi je pense que franchement on peut
être alors venir oui
la réalité c'est que moi j'ai eu
l'occasion de l'avoir au téléphone assez
récemment et elle nous dit pas ce qu'on
lui propose de façon récurrente de venir
à la maison de se mettre au vert mais
elle ne peut pas elle me dit attends
julie faut que tu comprennes aussi enfin
vous avez votre bonheur vous avez de
fausses votre famille quelque part nous
on est l'ombre c'est la lumière elle a
besoin de cette lumière donc à la aucun
intérêt finalement à venir il est pas si
c'est dur ce que vous dites oui c'est
très dur que vous dites mais c'est
c'est là c'est la vérité c'est à dire
que elle le dit et on a conscience que
la ce besoin d'être uniquement dans la
lumière c'est à dire dette
effectivement en retrait ça ne
l'intéresse pas mais il faut qu'elles
aient la chance d'avoir autre chose dans
la vie ça c'est pas facile je dis que ça
fait de légende qui dit que certains
lofteurs je crois que c'est un must et
vic quand ça n'allait pas bien pour
loana et qu'ils ont proposé de venir
effectivement elle a refusé toute aide
ah ouais alors ce que maman c'est que et
refusant même temps qu'on te jouer au
téléphone a dit oui je vais venir
revenir mais en fait non c'est à dire
qu'elle est là fétide et qu'elle
aimerait pouvoir venir mais elle n'est
pas du tout en capacité parce que ça ne
l'intéresse pas c'est pas du tout ce
qu'elle fait là aussi mais ça l'a
détruit d'être comme ça parce qu'on va
piquer quelles étaient ses 600 et où
c'est elle sera en vacances car elle a
été au bout 5 est là elle a connu les
enfers va pas s'écrouler devant le bol
de sangria entre guillemets s'était
lassé les vingt ans c'est pas maintenant
qu'ils y voilà qui il faut qu'elle
arrive à terminer ex histoire faut que
la france elle garde une bonne image de
loi nâ 1 et kasai enfin vivre sa vie est
belle nous nous laissons d'abord
évidemment sur le bateau avec vous pour
les pour les 20 ans mais c'est vrai que
loana dans une vie normale on dit ça va
être quand même compliqué on va garder
un dernier extrait elle pourra plus
maintenant revenir dans la danse dans la
vie réelle fouquet là il faudrait
trouver un compromis
faut qu'elle arrive à tirer profit de
est à la fois de son émergence avec le
loft est à la fois de sa trajectoire
tragique qui c'était le dire pour
essayer de faire un trouver un équilibre
avec tout ça elle pourra plus aller
bosser
elle en est capable on pas se mentir on
pourra parler bosses et gué c'est un
mammouth non avec la route
j'aurais pu vous le faire gagner sur le
plateau les remercier christophe
déjeuner on va croire
j'avais des attentes